i can't be the first to ask
but what with his rockets satellites and
ai monkeys is there something elon musk
knows that he's not telling us
everyone's favorite billionaire the
brainiac that sends tremendous through
the stock market with a simple change of
his twitter bio
has launched another batch of his spacex
styling satellites on a rocket
but not the one that just exploded that
was just a test
he wants to create high-speed broadband
internet in space
he's got well over a thousand satellites
up in space already
and apparently he now controls over 25
of all active satellites in orbit
and when the newly minted richest man on
planet earth spoke to new
voice app clubhouse earlier in the week
he told them
about one of his more earthly companies
neuralink has already taken a monkey put
an implant in its brain
so i can play video games with its mind
but don't worry because elon said you
can't see where the implant is and he's
a happy monkey
i'm sure there are worse things in life
than being elon's monkey
in a recent tweet he said neurolink is
working super hard to ensure implant
safety and is in close communication
with the fda
if things go well we might be able to do
initial human trials later this year
nice one samia
but he is trying to find out the meaning
of life and after reading the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
you wanted to go out and explore the
galaxy
the conversation on clubhouse did
venture to the darker side of things
though
he said that all civilizations fall and
that
it's a race what comes first a
self-sustaining civilization on mars
or world war three
and speaking of mars elon thinks in
about five and a half years he'll get
there
all depending on speed and fuel cost
and there'll be no international law on
mars to follow either
and to be fair it's not like he follows
the rules down here
is it well i think i just declared king
of mars a moment ago
i don't know i just hope i'm on that
spaceship to mars
sitting next to elon looking in the
rearview mirror
just before earth explodes what could
possibly go wrong